o sea yo yo creo que peleé después que
dejó de jugar fútbol pasó a dedicarse a
una carrera de hombre de negocio o sea
fundamentalmente estaba dedicado a su
marca y viajaba el mundo un poco como
embajador de del fútbol del deporte no
es una persona que se ha mantenido
conectada con el deporte O sea no ha
sido entrenador No no ha sido jugador
tuvo un paso corto como comentarista
deportivo en emisora de televisión
durante la Copa del Mundo de Estados
Unidos pero fíjate que no ha sido ni
siquiera miembro del cuerpo directivo
del santo Fútbol Club no ha sido
director de la confederación brasileña
de fútbol él muy conscientemente y yo
pienso que muy acertadamente muy
correctamente
decidió alejarse de la práctica del
fútbol sea la práctica deportivo o
administrativa porque tenía una
percepción muy aguda de que dejaba una
contribución muy positiva y yo creo que
eligió decidió parar en el abscis en
lugar de entrar en una decadencia de
rendimiento o también de meterse en
política y quizá destruir la imagen
positivo que que tiene la marca Pelé lo
único que ha hecho es que ha sido
comentador comentarista de deporte en la
copa de Estados Unidos y también ha
hecho una incursión en la política como
ministro de deportes del expresidente
Fernando Enrique Cardozo y ha hecho
leyes bastante positivas respecto a las
transacciones comerciales en el fútbol
pero se ha mantenido discreto y yo creo
que ha sido una decisión muy acertada
porque él tenía una conciencia muy
nítida del legado que que tenía su
nombre y su imagen como jugador de
fútbol y decidió no no prolongar esta
experiencia como corriendo el riesgo de
dilapidarla de alguna manera no